we begin with the surging omicron
variant which is spreading at a rapid
rate in the united kingdom health
experts warn that it's the most
significant threat to public health
since the start of this pandemic and on
wednesday the uk recorded its highest
ever daily number of cases more than 78
thousand dw correspondent charlotte
chelsea pill reports from london
[Music]
festive cheer on the streets of london
once again ringing hollow
shops and hospitality may all be open
christmas parties still allowed to go
ahead as planned
but covert is casting its dark shadow
over the days ahead as experts warn the
omicron tidal wave is coming and it's
coming at a phenomenal pace
what we know
is that it reproduces very very fast um
a week ago or so we said it
reproduces every two to three days or
three times a week and putting it very
simply that means in one week you get
eight times as many infections two weeks
sixty four times as many three weeks 512
times as many so it's coming at us like
an express train
the uk is already recording
record-covered cases with omicron now
the dominant variant here in london
resisting calls from some for further
restrictions the government's focusing
instead on its booster campaign
resulting in lengthy cues at vaccine
sites across the country
obviously the omicron is growing so
rapidly in london and we just wanted to
get in as quickly as possible so many
people that i've heard of are getting
covert again
from last week i'd have there was an
office party of 14 16 of them got
covered clearly omicron is really
spreading quickly it's very relevant or
very important for me to come here today
for all five hours
not that i want to make an issue of it
but um i live with my mother and father
who have been there ages i wanted to
ideally get it done before i went to go
and see
relatives and people over christmas i
can't feel my toes though but it's okay
it's okay
the government's throwing the doors open
to every adult in england to get boosted
by the end of the year they're hoping to
offer up to a million jabs a day as
early data suggests the third vaccine is
key to combating omagra this is a
massive undertaking for the health
service they're being asked for another
major vaccine push to try and prevent
hospitals like this one from being
overwhelmed but there are concerns it
won't be enough as people here line up
for their boosters there are already
people in hospital with omicron
hospitalizations are climbing and one
person's confirmed to have died with
omicron
while it's not yet clear how severe the
variant is the sheer number of cases
alone could prove overwhelming
in the shadow of this vaccine center a
reminder of what's at stake
a memorial wall commemorating the tens
of thousands of lives lost to covid
and it's with the pain and sacrifice of
the past that this weary nation is now
facing the threat of another worrying
winter to come
our next guest is danny altman he's a
professor of immunology in london and he
joins us now mr altman thank you for
taking the time to speak with us i want
to start with the report that we just
saw where charlotte outlined the very
severe situation that the united kingdom
finds itself right now due to the
omicron variant which is now the
dominant variant in london based on
everything you've seen so far do you
think that this british government has
done enough
i think
scientists and experts were pleased to
see them doing something and going to um
to their plan b so in other words more
behavioral measures
and um greater emphasis on boosting um
whether we've done enough any time will
tell this looks really really serious
and we probably need to do more
do you think that the fact that they
lifted the mask mandate some time ago
which then now they've reinstated do you
think that that hurt efforts
i think it did um
i think um you know we we have this um
discussion don't we about whether this
is all about vaccine boosters or whether
it's about vaccine boosters plus all the
behavioral measures like masks and the
answer is it's absolutely about both um
in this country we kind of had our
freedom day and and took our foot off
the gas and now we need to revisit some
of those choices
the freedom day that you're referring to
was announced by prime minister boris
johnson back in the summer where all the
restrictions were lifted and he said
we're going to return to normal and
clearly that hasn't been the case and it
certainly isn't the case now leading up
into christmas what is your biggest
concern mr altman now in the united
kingdom as we approach christmas and
potentially more travel
well you know your items has covered the
terms hasn't it like um tidal wave and
express train
and that's what's coming to us it's
coming to much of the rest of the world
and something that's so infectious and
spreading through the population so fast
can really devastate us both in terms of
its death toll and its effect on health
services
talk to us a little bit more about the
impact on health services doctors nurses
have gone through much already in the
nearly past two years and now they're
facing this omicron variant and some
people are not willing to get vaccinated
what kind of impact could this have now
in the coming weeks and months with
regard to the health system in the
united kingdom
it's so extreme you know we're now two
years into this aren't we of a very
exhausted and beleaguered and injured
and overstretched health service um and
i think people here a um logistically
aren't in a position to cope anymore and
b simply don't have the capacity in
terms of hospital beds and intensive
care beds to deal with the kind of surge
that it looks like we're facing
dr danny altman professor of immunology
in the imperial college of london thank
you very much for your time
so that is the situation in britain but
what about the rest of the world let's
bring in trolls lilibeck he is the head
of denmark's coronavirus variant
assessment committee a very warm welcome
to the show professor denmark has one of
europe's best virus screening programs
in terms of sequencing and in that sense
it can provide something of an early
warning system for what's ahead so tell
us what is coming for the rest of us
with omicron
what we also see in denmark is is that
the rates are doubling every second or
third day so we are seeing you know a
lot of testing positive every day we
have new record last
24 hours nearly 9 000 cases and we have
also
a larger and larger proportion of those
cases are omicron cases
so breaking records we know omicron
spreads like wildfire but we're still
not sure if it's actually more harmful
than let's say the delta variant is that
correct
yeah yeah that's correct that we're not
sure but i think even if it's half as
harmful as the delta variant the problem
is the total number of cases because if
we reach a very very high number of
cases that would be tenth of thousands
in denmark then even if it's half as
dangerous still the total strain on the
hospital system will be extremely high
and a lot of the staff members in
hospital nursing rooms all those kind of
functions they have to go home because
they test positive perhaps they have
mild symptoms but still they cannot take
care of the other ones in the hospital
or those who need help so so that's the
problem anyway
so just be clear the biggest threat that
we know that it could be coming with
omicron is that you'll have too many
people infected at the same time uh even
if it's not as serious some of those
will be showing up in hospitals and all
overwhelming the hospital system at the
same time
exactly yes that that is the problem so
so we we do not know if it is it's
causing less disease than delta but but
you could say it doesn't really matter
because if you get all the cases at the
same time and then you have a very
severe problem so that is what we are
trying to avoid right now in denmark by
very very huge vaccination campaigns we
have different meshes in place
and and and do all kinds of things in
order to not have all the cases at the
same time to get distributed on on more
days or weeks so to say
let's talk about those campaigns because
we keep hearing that vaccination is key
also now that two jabs aren't enough
against omicron virologists are urging
everyone to get a third booster shot but
is that really the best strategy given
that in many countries especially in the
global south the majority of people
haven't even had their first job
no i think what
we know now for for certain that when
you get your boosted errors then you
have a good effect about
symptomatic infections and you have a
good effect about uh hospitalization and
and what we all feel that would be to to
get hospitalized to get severely sick so
so i think that that is the best weapon
also because it seems that omicron
spreads very easily so so so it will be
difficult to avoid the the this variant
just just by restrictions you still need
the restrictions not to get this very
very high peak at once or at least
trying to avoid it but but but i would
say that vaccinations is the best
defense even after two vaccines it seems
that there is some effect against
serious disease thanks to these memory
cells so it's not all about antibodies
but but vaccinations are certainly the
key
now one of the kinds of restrictions
that governments are imposing is to try
and limit movement and we learned today
that france is restricting travel uh to
from the uk to try and curb the spread
of omicron how much good is that going
to do can we not already assume that the
variant is all over europe and could
become the dominant strain here soon
absolutely i think
the variant is already there i think
it's a matter of how much you look after
it in the society in denmark we do 200
000 pt pcr tests per day an additional
250 000 rapid tests and remember we have
a population of 5.8 million so that's
nearly half million tests per day so we
discover omicron at a very very early
stage and in the beginning it's doubling
from you know two to four four to eight
eight to 16 and so on when you have a
delta outbreak at the same time you will
not discover the initial doubling so i
think that's happening in in many
european countries someday unless they
monitor very closely what is happening
on all the positive cases so so at some
point suddenly you know omicron will
peak through the the delta cases so i'm
sure that that is happening most places
in europe right now you see the norway
you say in uk you see it in denmark
where we do a lot of genotyping and and
do a lot of pcr
the whole population tested nearly every
week or something like that
so so so it's already there i don't
think travel restrictions is the way to
go now it just doesn't really make any
sense charles lillaback the head of
denmark's chronovirus variant assessment
committee thanks so much for coming on
the show with those insights
you're welcome
now for a breakdown of some pandemic
developments elsewhere in the world
south korea has authorized its toughest
pandemic restrictions to date starting
saturday private gatherings will be
limited to five people schools will go
back to remote learning and restaurants
will close by 9 p.m and here in germany
there are plans to buy 92 million
vaccine doses for the new year the
announcement comes after the new health
minister warned of a jab shortage in the
first quarter of 2022. new zealand says
90 of its eligible population is now
fully inoculated the nation's health
regulator has also granted provisional
approval for the pfizer biontech vaccine
for five to 11 year olds
you